翻訳: Makoto Ueda
校正: Yuri Ueda
大きくなったら何になりたい？
先ほどの長野先生のお話の中にも
出てきた質問かもしれませんが
皆さんはこの質問に
小さい頃 何と答えていましたか
小学校１年生の頃 私は
「ケーキ屋さんになりたい」と答えていました
ケーキ屋さんになったら
毎日 余ったケーキが食べられると
思っていたからです
そんな他愛のない回答をしていた時期が
皆さんにもあったかもしれません
それから だいぶ大きくなった今
改めて 「大きくなったら何になりたい？」
と聞かれたら
皆さんなら どう答えますか？
「何になりたい」
「何がしたい」
「どういう人生を歩みたい」
これらは私たちの人生の中で
常に問い続けなければならない問題でしょう
そして 私たちは人生の中で
重要な選択を迫られた時にこそ
強くこの問いを意識することに
なると思います
どこの学校に行くか どこに就職するか
地元に残るか 地元を離れるか
仕事を続けるか 転職するか
今まで多くの人が
このような選択を迫られた時に
悩み 迷い 苦しみ
そして決断してきたことと思います
かくいう私自身も まさに今
そのような人生の岐路に立たされて
迷っている一人です
今は大学院で物理を研究していますが
将来何になるの？
卒業したら何するの？
そんな問いに 私はいつも
「さぁ どうなんだろうね」と
お茶を濁してきました
自分が一体何になりたいのか
はっきりした答えが持てないままでした
そんな風に 私が漠然とした不安や焦りに
苛まれている最中にも
ふと周りを見渡すと
俺 アメリカで研究がしたい
世界平和に貢献したい
宇宙飛行士になりたい など
将来これがしたい という明確な目標を掲げて
そしてその実現に向けて 一生懸命
努力している友人が 沢山いました
そんな彼らを見て
「すごいなぁ」と 本当に尊敬しながらも
一方で 「じゃあ一体自分は
何になりたいんだろう」と いう
不安と焦りが 益々大きくなってきました
私はまるで 「なりたいもの探し」の
迷路に迷い込んだようでした
その迷路を抜け出すヒントを少しでも得ようと
私はまず Googleに頼りました
（笑）
Googleは何でも教えてくれました
就職のこと 仕事のこと
会社のこと 社会のこと
大学院の博士課程のこと 留学のこと
しかし この次から次へと溢れ出てくる
種々雑多な言葉を
ディスプレイ越しにじっと眺めていても
結局 自分がやりたいことが何なのか
よくわかりませんでした
そこで 私は作戦を変えて
今の私と同じように
人生の選択をしてきた いろんな人々に
話を聞いてみることにしました
両親 研究室の先生や先輩方
就職して会社でバリバリ働いている方
みんなとても親身になって
アドバイスをくれました
「自分も同じように悩んだよ」
「一番の決め手は
自分が『かっこいい』って思える道を
選ぶことだったよ」など
インターネット上の言葉じゃない
自分の境遇をよく理解してくれる人たちの
温かい言葉がたくさんありました
でもそれでも　自分のやりたいことが何なのか
まだわからないままでした
私がこのTEDxAnjoに出会ったのは
そんな「なりたいもの探し」の迷路に
完全に迷い込んでいた最中のことでした
オーディションを終えて
改めて 私にどんなトークができるかを
スタッフの方々と話し合っていた時のことです
私は 自分が今夢中になっている
物理や言語などのマニアックな話を
一生懸命 熱く語っていた時のことでした
スタッフの方が 僕の話を聞いて
こんな事を言ってくれました
「鈴木さんは
何かを学ぶということに
価値を置いているのかもしれませんね」
価値―
今まで考えたこと無かったけれど
自分が「価値」を置いていることって
一体 何だろう
自分の持っている価値観って
一体 何なんだろう
そもそも価値観って 一体何だと思いますか
私はこう考えます
この世の中にある いろんな
モノ ヒト 行動 選択
生き方 考え方
それらに対して 自分が何に重きを置くか
何を善とし 何を悪とするか
何を美しいと思い 何を醜いと思うか
そういう自分だけの
オリジナルな主観的な物差し
それが価値観だと
そして この自分を主体とした価値観
これこそが「なりたいもの探し」の
迷路を抜けるヒントになるのではないか
じゃあ 私の価値観って一体 何だろう
これまでの23年間を振り返ってみて
改めて自分の価値観がどんなものであるか
次の四つの質問を通して 考えてみました
皆さんも 自身の価値観について
これからちょっと一緒に考えてみませんか
一つ目
好きなことは何ですか？
やっていて楽しいこと ワクワクすること
感動することは何ですか
私は物理です
大学に入ってから
本格的に学び始めた物理だけど
この世界を司る いろんな法則が
方程式で書き下すことができて
それを解けば
この世のいろんな現象を記述できる
それが素晴らしいと思いませんか
例えば この単純な運動方程式で
投げたボールやジェットコースター
宇宙に浮かぶ天体や人工衛星など
いろんな物の運動が記述できる
私たちの生活に欠かせない
光や電気 磁気
その性質が
このマクスウェル方程式で記述できる
そして 私たちの住んでいる世界よりも
もっとミクロな
電子 分子 原子の世界
その世界は
このシュレーディンガ―方程式で記述できる
(笑)
この物理のもつ驚くべき力に
何かワクワクしてきませんか？
(笑)
二つ目
昔からずっと興味のあることは 何ですか？
私は言語です
今まで 英語 中国語 フランス語
ロシア語 アラビア語 そして手話
いろんな言語に挑戦してきたけれど
どの言語も それぞれ固有の構造をもっていて
それを解き明かすのがすごく面白い
そして異なる言語の間での
類似点を見つけるのも面白い
今まで理解できなかった文字列が
ある時 急に意味のある文章に
なってくるのが面白い
（中国語）私は中国語を勉強しています
（フランス語）私はフランス語を勉強しています
（ロシア語）私はロシア語を勉強しています
（アラビア語）私はアラビア語を勉強しています
こんなのが意味を持った文章に見えてくると
何かそれだけで
世界が広がったような気がして
何かワクワクしてきませんか
(笑)
三つ目
今までの人生の中で印象に残っている
思い出は何ですか？
私は旅です
今まで国内は北海道から沖縄まで
海外も ロシア カナダ ウズベキスタンなど
いろんな地域を訪れて
それぞれの地域の
文化や食べ物を楽しんだ―
それは 私にとって
かけがえのない思い出です
そして四つ目
今までのあなたの考え方 生き方に
大きな影響を与えたものは何ですか？
私は周りの人々との会話でした
今まで考え方も価値観も
ぜんぜん違う いろんな人と出会って
いろんな話をして
自分だけでは 絶対に気づけなかった視点から
ものごとを見られるようになって
それで自分の見える世界が
どんどん どんどん広がっていった
それを強く実感しており
周りの人々に 大変感謝しています
世界を広げる
これが私が価値を置いてることなんじゃないか
そういう考えに至りました
知らなかったことを知る
できなかったことが できるようになる
見たことのないものを見る
行ったことのない場所に行く
その過程で得られる新たな発見が純粋に面白い
これからもそんな感覚を味わい続けたいし
振り返ってみれば これまでも
無意識にそのようなことを求めて行動し
選択していたのかもしれません
自分の「価値観」を発見して
具体的な「なりたいもの」は見つかったのか
いいえ まだ見つかっていません
だけど「世界を広げる」という
自分の価値観を発見してから
これからも視野を狭めずに
まだ知らない世界にも
臆することなく飛び込んでいって
自分だけの人生を作り上げていきたい
という思いが 強くなってきました
「自分の価値観」を言葉にしてみて
自分の考えや行動に
一つの大きな軸ができたんじゃないか
そう考えています
大きくなったら何になりたい？
私たちはこれからも
人生で岐路に立たされた時に
常に この問いを自分自身に
投げかけることになるでしょう
複数の選択肢が与えられた時
それらを見比べて
メリット デメリットを書き比べてみても
答えは見つからないかもしれません
Googleに聞いても
答えを教えてくれないかもしれません
それはきっと
「自分の価値観」ではないから
そんな時は
自分の中に目を向けて
眠っている自分の声に耳を傾けて
それを言葉にして出してみませんか
そうして得られた
「自分の価値観」に基づいた選択は
どんな選択であれ
自分にとって
とても価値のある人生の１ページになる
そう信じています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）